ALEXIS MOUSSINE-POUCHKINE:
Containers have drastically
changed the workflow
of many developers.
And so you might wonder,
how do I run containers
on Google Cloud Platform?
In this video, we'll
review three ways you
can run your containers on GCP.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
While the concepts underlying
containers have been around
for many years,
Docker, Kubernetes,
and an entire ecosystem of
products and best practices
have emerged in
the last few years
enabling many different
kinds of applications
to be containerized.
As a developer, containers
give you a lot of freedom
by letting you package an app
with all of its dependencies
into an easy-to-move package.
The solutions for
running containers in GCP
vary essentially in how much of
the underlying infrastructure
is exposed.
The first way you can
run a container on GCP
is to use Google
Kubernetes Engine, or GKE.
As the inventor of
Kubernetes, Google quite
naturally offers a fully
managed Kubernetes service,
taking care of scheduling
and scaling your containers
while monitoring their
health and state.
Getting your code
to production on GKE
can be as simple as
creating a container
deployment with the cluster
being provisioned on the fly.
Once running, GKE clusters
are secure by default, highly
available, monitored, and
they run on Google Cloud's
high-speed network.
They can also be fine tuned for
zonal and regional locations
and can use specific
machine types
with optional GPUs or TPUs.
GKE clusters also offer
hassle-free operations,
with auto scaling,
auto-repair of failing nodes,
and an auto-upgrade
to the latest
stable version of Kubernetes.
GKE is also a key
component of Anthos,
Google Cloud's enterprise
hybrid and multi-cloud platform.
With Anthos, you can also
migrate existing VMs directly
into containers and move
your workloads freely
between on-premises and cloud
environments, such as GCP.
What if you could focus on
building your stateless app,
not on writing YAML
files, and still deliver
code packaged in a container?
The second way you can deploy
your containers on Google Cloud
is with Cloud Run.
This gives you the benefits of
both containers and serverless.
There is no cluster or
infrastructure to provision
or manage.
And Cloud Run
automatically scales any
of your stateless containers.
Creating a Cloud Run
service with your container
only requires selecting a
location, giving it a name,
and setting authentication
requirements.
Cloud Run supports multiple
requests per container.
And it works with any language,
any library, any binary,
and even any base Docker image.
The result is service
with true pay-for-usage,
the ability to scale to
zero, and full out-of-the-box
monitoring, logging,
and error reporting.
Because Cloud Run is built
using the Knative open source
project, which offers a
serverless abstraction on top
of Kubernetes, you can have your
own private hosting environment
and deploy the
exact same container
workload on Cloud Run for
Anthos in GCP or on prem.
The third option for
deploying your containers
is straight to Google
Compute Engine, or GCE.
That's right, you can leverage
your familiar virtual machine
environment to run
your containers.
This means using your
existing workflow and tools
without requiring your team
to ramp up on all things cloud
native.
When creating a GCE
virtual machine,
the container
section will let you
specify the image
you'd like to use,
as well as a few
important options.
When you get to the
boot disk section,
the suggested virtual
machine OS is something
called a Container-Optimized
OS, an operating system
optimized for running
Docker containers
and maintained by Google.
This operating system image
comes with a Docker Runtime
pre-installed, thus enabling
you to bring up your Docker
container at the same time you
create your virtual machine.
But it also lacks
most of what you
expect to find in a
typical Linux distribution,
such as a package manager
and many other binaries.
This means a
lockdown environment
that ensures a smaller attack
surface, keeping your container
runtime as safe as possible.
The great thing about
running your containers
on Compute Engine is
that you can still
create scalable services
using managed instance groups,
as they offer auto scaling,
auto healing, rolling updates,
multi-zone deployment,
and load balancing
for the compute instances.
Where do these container
images come from?
Where do I store them?
How do I version them?
And how do I restrict
access to them?
The answer lies in Google
Container Registry, or GCR,
which is a private-by-default
Container Registry that
runs on GCP with
consistent uptime
and across multiple regions.
You can push, pull,
and manage images
in GCR from any system, VM
instance, or your own hardware,
and maintain control
over who can access,
view, and download those images.
Note, also, how you
can conveniently deploy
to all three run times
we've discussed straight
from Container Registry,
deploy to Cloud Run,
to Container Engine,
and to Compute Engine.
Container Registry works with
popular continuous delivery
systems, such as Cloud
Build, Spinnaker, or Jenkins
to automatically build
containers on code or tag
changes to repository.
Finally, Container
Analysis scans
containing images
stored in the registry
for known
vulnerabilities, and keeps
you informed so that you can
review and address issues
before deployment.
Google Cloud offers
you three solid ways
to run your containers, ranging
from a fully managed Kubernetes
environment to a truly
serverless platform.
Pick the solution that
works best for you,
and start deploying your
containerized workloads today.
Consider trying some free code
labs linked in the description
below to explore these products,
and look forward to upcoming
episodes and more overviews.
If you like this video, please
like, subscribe, comment,
share, and look forward to
more GCP Essentials videos.
[MUSIC PLAYING]